hello this is the second in the series
of dr sandra talk and talk videos
in which i am responding at greater
length to questions that have been asked
to me in other formats
most notably in vu
or sometimes by email some questions
that have come up in classes or have
been brought up to me in other formats
so
this is a follow-up
and in this
one i am addressing a question that came
up in vu
in relation to the idea of soul mates
and
somebody asked me do you believe in soul
mates i've already talked about that in
another video
so i said yes i do believe in soul mates
and they ask me does that mean
having a perfect marriage
no fighting complete harmony
and that's an interesting question as
well
and i think that in order to make sense
of it
it helps to
think about what it means to be soul
mates
there's a very easy answer to this one
which is no
as a matter of fact i don't know anybody
who has a marriage that's perfect
where they never fight or there's
complete harmony i know some couples who
don't fight on the surface but sometimes
they their intentions
underneath and over time people change
their priorities may bring them away
from each other
so these are these are good questions
let's look at this by thinking of it in
terms of this whole notion of soulmates
that's assuming that you you buy into
this this conception of a soulmate so
what do we mean by that
well
there are some classical understandings
one of
the
most interesting
and
even funny understandings comes from
this guy
aristophanes actually comes from plato
plato tells us that aristophanes
tells this story in a uh a dialogue
called the symposium where all of them
are supposed to give speeches about love
and
aristophanes does not give a speech
precisely about love
what he does instead is he tells a story
and it's a funny story
so here's here's how it goes in the
beginning
human beings didn't look the way that we
do now as a matter of fact
um
we're only half of what was left
after the gods divided us originally
imagine human beings where
instead of having a back like this there
was another human being affixed to it so
we had two faces
and we had four legs and four arms and
we moved around by rolling
and we were very powerful we were very
powerful beings
and as often happens in greek myths uh
what do the beings that are too powerful
do they get too big for their britches
they start tackling the gods and so the
guys decide we need to put an end to
this so they split them in half and
after they split them in half
a fixed just sews up the back part and
pulls everything together in the front
and that's where we get the belly button
from
now
what happens when these halves are split
from each other
aristophanes says
there are three kinds of beings
there were those that had two sets of
male sex organs
there were those who had two sets of
female sex organs and then there is the
kind that had one
set of male sex organs and once the
female sex organs
and
each of those had a half that they were
missing once they were split apart
so if you have a man
or male part
and a woman part of the original same
being and it can split right down the
middle
well now these two parts are separate
from each other but they yet long to
have that unity
with each other and so what they would
do then is they would find each other if
they could and just grasp onto each
other you know embrace and not do much
of anything else
so
not much was getting done
and many of them were dying from not
eating and you know not taking care of
themselves
so they started rearranging some other
things
and
i'm not going to go through the whole
myth right now
suffice it to say that the notion here
is that
on some level on some level of our being
human beings whether attracted to the
same sex or attracted to to opposite
sexes
for each one that's out there there's
another one that corresponds to them
best
now in aristotle's myth actually if one
partner dies
then the one who's alive goes looking
for another one likely so it's not as if
their soul mates in the sense of i have
only this one that only this woman will
will do for me
it's more like types you might say
but that gives you an understanding of
one
way of looking at that soul mates
there's somebody out there who is your
other half
you're missing half your better half
perhaps or sometimes you're worse half
so that's your
um aristotle also talks about friendship
in this way that their true friends
are like uh two soul or
one soul and two bodies
and that's akin to this notion of soul
mates as well so
what are some other notions well
if you think about
romantic plays novels
songs
and you also think about classical
conceptions
of the cosmos and of human affairs
you can talk in terms of people being
somehow
connected to each other oriented towards
each other and i'm going to talk about
three different three different ways to
understand this
three very different ways actually
there's the notion of fate
somebody is destined to another person
why
we don't know
there's no actual rational explanation
if you just say fate
you're not actually explaining much
other than to say that there's something
going on beyond what we see what we feel
what we hear
there's something beyond that that
connects things together
you know there are anthropomorphic
conceptions of the fates you know the
greeks had some the norse had some they
liked this metaphor of weaving
threads together so think of soul mates
perhaps
as being two people whose threads are
woven together by this fairly irrational
blind force
which
can be resistant to some degree but
probably never fully invaded once you
have a fake you're you're stuck with it
and you can't really get away from it
in eastern religions you have this
conception of karma and some conceptions
of soul mates that you find
in the east and also in western
appropriations of eastern thought
rely on this notion of karma
karmic attachment and also on the
associated conception of reincarnation
so if i have a soul mate according to
that conception
then she and i have crossed paths in
previous lives
and we are somehow connected to each
other and there could be a variety of
ways in which this took place
interestingly if you accept this notion
of reincarnation
then one sexuality becomes a function of
one's presence of life
and not necessarily of one's past life
as a matter of fact in countries that
believe in reincarnation they tend to be
male-dominated countries so if you're
born as a woman your lot of life is not
as good as those who are born men
and
the conception is you must have done
something wrong if you're born a man you
must have been pretty good in your last
life
now let's put that gender dynamics
stuff aside and let's think about this
if you have a soul mate
that means that
through life after life after life
somehow you are coming together and then
you live together for a while
maybe fall in love
and then one of you dies and goes off
into
as they say in another womb
and then the other one dies goes off
into another room they're reborn and
they will somehow find each other and
come together again and the world will
contribute ways in which this can take
place okay that's a very interesting
conception
if you think in terms of traditional
monotheism you know judaism and
christianity islam
if you think in terms of a
magnificent
mission
creator and arranger of affairs
a god who cares about humanity and what
goes on within the world
then you have the notion of a
providential order
and
if you think of the notion of soul mates
in that case
then you might actually get something
very close to the conception of
that we have in christianity
of vocation to marriage
if for example i am supposed to be the
soul mate of this woman over here one
way of thinking about that and this is
in fact the way i prefer to think about
it
is i have a vocation to be with her
as her spouse
and that i won't be fully complete i
won't have my
other hand i don't have what makes me
makes my potentials come out what makes
me flourish
unless i'm with her
and i could be with other women
but i won't be
fulfilled
in the way that i was designed to be
that i was intended to be providentially
unless i'm actually with her
and i suppose unless i am doing the
things that i want to be doing with her
and this takes me to my
third conception that i want to talk
about we have aristophanes certain
common conception we have these
different conceptions of
fate or karma or providence some
something beyond us
bringing us together
where is our responsibility in this i
like to think of this notion of becoming
soul mates
even if you assume anything like this if
you have another half that was destined
to you because you were you know
originally part of the same hole or if
there's something like this going on
there's still room for the individual
human beings the persons
who are involved there to exercise some
sort of agency to take some sort of
active role you know think about it our
potential as human beings
is quite often latent unless we bring it
out
and
you know a lot of times when they talk
about human potential many of the people
who advocate that use that sort of
language they think in terms of the
individual
what if instead we think in terms of
relationships
what if we adopt what we call a
personalistic attitude
where the human person is not understood
solely as an individual but through
their relationships that we exist
through our relationships
well if you have a soul mate
in a way it's because you actually make
the right choices with that person
and so do they with you and you
collaborate together on certain
basic goods that can only be
attained and truly worked out when both
of you are cooperating with each other
you know for example if you think about
sexuality
you can go out and screw just about
anybody you like
and not necessarily form much of an
attachment other than some sort of lost
you know you have endorphins that go
through your brain but you may not
actually like that person
you you may wake up next to them in the
morning and say oh my god i've made a
terrible mistake
what sexuality offers us is potential
is the capacity to develop
deeper and deeper levels of intimacy
but that requires choices that requires
working like i put here
growing through you know conflict
sometimes
growing through the choices that we make
now to go back to this original question
if you find your soul mate are you gonna
have a perfect marriage are you not
gonna have any conflict how do we in
fact grow
how do we develop as moral beings how do
we develop as persons
it's sometimes you know through
education sometimes things work out well
but
so often it's through conflict it's
through
having to take opposite positions and
then work our way to see the other
person's point of view and the relative
validity that it has
and to learn to love people despite our
differences
with them i think that that may in fact
be
part of a fuller conception of being a
soul mate to the other person
so
i'm going to leave you with several
ending questions
here's another one that i've been
thinking about for some time let's say
there are soul mates does that mean that
everybody has a soul mate
maybe not it could be quite possible
that i have a soul mate but you don't
or you know vice versa
or perhaps we could be lucky enough to
have soul mates but that poor
you know
guy over there there's nobody for him
those are all possibilities
now if we think in terms of you know
fate destiny providence maybe there are
some things for everybody
does everybody deserve a soulmate
that's a good question too